all right I want to talk a little bit
about what happens when you have
multiple parties and gerrymandering
combined this is a quick review in the
main video we had this situation where
there are 15 voters eight of which are
Buffalo seven of which are Jackalope and
depending on how you draw the district's
you can get any result that you want you
can either have the buffalo win four to
one or you can get the Jackalope win
three to two
now this is not a good situation but it
gets worse if you add more political
parties so we're going to add in turtle
to the mixture here I need to make the
voting population a little bit bigger to
show you the effect so now we're going
to have a twenty five member population
there are six turtle voters nine
Jackalope voters and ten buffalo voters
and you can see on the right-hand side
that we have a pie chart showing the
overall proportion of the population the
best situations you can get with this
group is if you have one turtle district
you get two Jackalope districts and two
buffalo districts and then the
percentage of the representatives and
the percentage of the voters match
pretty closely but as you expect if you
gerrymander these districts around a
little bit you can change the results
quite dramatically first we can have
buffalo win an additional seat so they
get a majority in the house so they have
three districts against turtles one and
Jackalopes one you can completely push
the turtles out so Jackalope gets two
representatives and Buffalo gets three
representatives you can set it up so
that Jackalope who's a minority party
they actually end up getting the
majority in the house with three seats
two buffaloes two and in the weirdest
situation you can end up getting two
turtle representatives to three
Jackalope representatives and Buffalo
who's actually the largest section of
the population they get no
representation at all I think part of
the the trouble in actually explaining
gerrymandering and plurality voting is
because on an individual case-by-case
basis and each of these districts kind
of make sense and if you just take a
look at one for example right there's
three turtle voters there - buffalo
voters so it makes sense well this
district gets a turtle representative
while on a nationwide scale right you
might not get results that you want for
each individual case it's kind of hard
to argue against but the situation gets
much more complicated if you add more
parties so if we add in gorilla voters
and wolf voters here right now this
district is no longer a turtle district
it's now a buffalo district because
buffalo has the most voters right under
first-past-the-post slash plurality
that's all you need to actually win you
don't need a majority of the population
you just need the large
number of voters but this can quickly
lead to some pretty horrific Leon
representative results so we go back to
our 25 population if we turn a bunch of
those Jackalope and turtle voters into
third party voters we can take a look at
the overall population on that pie chart
you see again Buffalo is the plurality
of voters with 40% but you have 60% of
voters represent some other party but
under this districting situation none of
them get representatives except for the
Buffalo who win every single district
because they have two votes that are
concentrated versus three votes that are
separated and this is why if you have
districting and gerrymandering and
you're using first-past-the-post voting
it's really hard to have more than two
political parties because it's very easy
for the larger parties to just
completely push out any other
representation that you might get and I
didn't have the time to actually show a
larger population but just you can
quickly see you can make this as
ridiculous as you actually want to here
we just have five voters but if we
change it to 10 voters right Buffalo
still wins this district even though
there are only 20% of the population and
you can make this district as large as
you want and as long as you keep adding
additional separated voters you can make
Buffalo as smaller percentage as you
want but they still actually win the
district thank you very much watching